I want to continue in Volume 2, beginning in September the 21st, 1899.
Louisa has differences with Lady Obedience.
Yet who would have said it, Louisa said, "In spite of the fact that the wrong is hers,
and that she does not give me the capacity to manifest it, misobedience took offense
and began to act like a cruel tyrant.
And she reached such cruelty as to take the sight of my loving good away from me, my soul,
and only comfort.
It really shows that sometimes she also behaves like a little girl, when she has a whim for
something.
If she doesn't get it with good manners, she defens the house with screams and with
crying to the point that one is forced to content her.
There are no reasons, there's no way in the middle ground to persuade her.
So that's the way Lady Obedience does.
"Brava," she says.
I would not have thought you were like this.
Since she wants to get her own way, she wants me even stammering to write about charity.
Now, here's Louisa reacting badly to being asked to write about this great, great thing
called charity.
She feels she's not able to do it.
And that's why she's reacting.
And all she's got to do is step out and walk on water and let Jesus speak through her.
But she's really struggling.
"Oh, holy God, you yourself make her a little bit more reasonable because it really shows
that one cannot go on in this way.
And you, Obedience, give me back my sweet Jesus, don't cut me to the quick anymore.
I pray you not to take the sight of my highest good away from me anymore.
And I promise that even stammering I will write as you want."
I only ask you, of you, the good grace to let me recover for a few days because my mind
too little can no longer take being immersed in that vast ocean of divine charity, especially
because in it I see my miseries and my ugliness more, and in seeing the love that God has
for me, I feel I am almost going mad."
Now, you see, this thing is being repeated again and that is the more you perceive God's
love for you, the more you fall in love with him.
That's what she calls "I'm going mad."
But at the same time, you see all your own faults and miseries and failings as well.
Because when you're looking at God you're looking at truth, and therefore you see the
truth of yourself as well as the truth of everything else.
So my mind too little can no longer take being immersed in that vast ocean of divine charity,
especially because in it I can see my miseries and my ugliness more, and in seeing the love
of God has for me, I feel I'm almost going mad.
And so my weak nature feels faint and can take no more.
Song of songs 2, 5.
But in the meantime, I will occupy myself with writing about other things and then continue
with charity.
So I resume my poor communication, she says.
"While my mind was occupied with the things already said, I was thinking to myself, what
would be the purpose of writing this?
If I myself did not practice what I write, this writing would certainly be my condemnation.
While I was thinking of this, blessed Jesus came and told me, this writing will serve
to make known the one who is speaking to you and occupies your person.
In other words, it will reveal Jesus will you stop thinking about yourself.
And then if it doesn't serve you, my light will serve others who will read what I make
you write."
Now, Louisa hasn't grasped in the little bit that I've just read that when Holy Obedience
asks her to do something that God is asking her to do it, and Jesus says here very clearly,
"What I make you write."
And he says to her, "If you don't benefit from it, others will."
So write, which has great reluctance in writing.
Who can say how mortified I was, Louisa said, that others would take advantage of the graces
he gives me, if they read these writings and I who receive them do not.
Will they not condemn me?
And then at the mere thought that they may end up in the hands of others, my heart aches
with pain and with blushing for myself, 1 Corinthians 9, 27.
Now remaining in greatest affliction, I kept saying, "What is the purpose of my state
if it's just to serve as condemnation?"
And my most loving Jesus coming back told me, "My life was necessary for the salvation
of all people, and since I could not continue it on the earth, I choose whom I please."
In order to continue it within them, that's Louisa.
So as to continue the salvation of the peoples, in other words, Jesus continues his redemptive
work through the body of Christ, and there are certain members of the body of Christ
like victim-sold who are called to this work more than the rest of us.
And he said, "That's the purpose of your state."
But she's still having problems with writing in September 22, 1899.
Louisa says, "I feel a nail stuck in my heart because of the word spoken yesterday by my
sweet Jesus.
And he always kind with this miserable sinner to relieve my pains he came and all compassion
for me he told me.
My daughter, do not want to afflict yourself any longer.
Do not want means don't put your will into it."
In other words, don't go into a self-pity party.
Don't put your will into it.
Know that everything I make you right.
Now who is the origin of this message?
It's Jesus.
Who is it for?
It's for his kingdom.
Who is it to release, it is to release the divine will upon the earth?
Know that everything I make you right either about virtues or in the form of similes is
nothing but making you portray yourself and the perfection which I made your soul reach.
And Louisa's reaction was, "Oh God, what a great repugnance I feel in writing these
words because what he says does not seem true to me.
I feel I still don't understand what virtue and perfection is, but obedience wants so,
and it is better to croak than having to deal with her."
More so since she has two faces.
If one does as she says she assumes the appearance of a lady and caresses you like a most faithful
friend, even more she promises you all the goods that are in heaven and on earth.
But then as soon as she detects a shadow of difficulty against her immediately without
letting herself be noticed, one goes about looking at her and finds her a warrior in the
act of arming his weapons to wound you and destroy you.
Oh my Jesus, what kind of virtue is disobedience that makes one tremble at the mere thought
of her?
Notice the way she shifts from male to female images there quite easily.
Then while Jesus was saying these words to me, I told him, "My good Jesus, what good
is it for my soul to have so many graces?
If then they embit her my whole life, especially because of the hours of your privation.
In fact, understanding who you are and of whom I am being deprived, it is a continuous
martyrdom for me.
So they serve me for nothing but to keep me continuously embittered."
And Jesus said, "When a person has tasted the sweetness of a food and then is forced
to take the bitter, in order to remove that bitterness, he doubles his desire to taste
the sweet."
And this does much good to that person because if he always tasted the sweet without ever
tasting bitterness, he would not take the sweet into great consideration.
In other words, you need balance in the spiritual life.
As you need balance in all life, we need night to balance the day.
We need darkness to balance the light.
We need mourning to balance the evening and so on and so on.
But if the person always tasted bitterness without knowing what the sweet is and by not
knowing it, he would not even desire it, therefore both one and the other do good.
So it's good for you also to taste both bitter and sweet.
So Louisa said, "My Jesus most patient in bearing a soul so miserable and ungrateful
forgive me.
It seems to me that this time I want to investigate too much."
And Jesus said, "Do not be disturbed.
You're not allowed to be disturbed.
You must keep a very calm interior."
It is I myself who raised these difficulties in your interior to have the occasion to converse
with you and also to instruct you in everything.
This is very important.
Not only does Jesus allow these problems to crop up in her, but Louisa struggles and finding
these answers from the Lord is very important instruction for us as well.
And an awful lot of these instructions are more for us than for her.
September the 25th, 1899, Louisa is the defender of Jesus and of people.
In my mind, I was thinking, if these writings end up in somebody's hands, this person might
say, "She must be a good Christian if the Lord gives her so many graces."
Not knowing that in spite of all this, I'm still so bad.
Here is how people can deceive themselves both in good and in evil.
"A Lord, you alone know the truth and the depth of the hearts.
While I was thinking of this blessed Jesus came and told me, 'My beloved,' and what
if people knew that you are my defender and theirs?
In other words, they won't get the message that you think they'll get.
They'll get the real message."
So Louisa said, "My Jesus, what are you saying?"
He said, "What?
Is it not true that you defend me from the pains that they give to me by placing yourself
between me and them?
That's called standing in the breach."
And you'll find it in Sam 106, verse 23.
And you'll find it also in Isaiah 58, verse 12, where the prophet laments that there's
nobody to stand in the breach to keep back the justice of God from sinners.
So he says, "That's the position of the intercessor and the victim soul that they would stand
in the breach.
So by placing yourself between me and them and that you take upon yourself the blow that
I am to receive, as well as that which I should pour down upon them, you're willing to give
me a refreshment by taking justice upon yourself and to give them a refreshment by taking justice
upon yourself.
And if sometimes you do not receive it upon yourself, it's because I don't allow it.
And this, to your great sorrow, to the point of lamenting to me, can you perhaps deny it?"
He said, "No Lord," he said, "I can't deny it.
But I see that it is something that you yourself have infused in me, John 15, 5, without me,
Jesus said, 'You can do nothing.'"
And this is why I say that it's not because I am good and I feel all confused in hearing
you speak these words to me," she said.
So September the 26th, 1899, oppositions to writing, "How the most holy virgin is a portant
of grace, abstract of sight and intuitive sight.
This morning my adorable Jesus came.
He carried me outside of myself, but to my greatest sorrow, I saw him from behind.
But as much as I prayed him to let me see his most holy face, it was impossible.
In my interior, I kept saying, "Who knows whether it's because of my oppositions against
the obedience to write that he doesn't dare to show his adorable face."
And while saying this, I cried.
After he let me cry, he turned around and he said, "I take your oppositions into no account,
because your will is so identified with mine that you cannot want but what I myself want."
Now, here is the first indication and it's only volume two where Louise's will is completely
identified with the divine will.
And this is what the Lord wants from us as well, that our wills be completely identified
with his.
And so he says to Louise, "In fact, at this point, you're only able to want what I want."
So though it is repugnant for you, at the same time you feel drawn to it as by a magnet,
therefore your repugnance is served for nothing else is to render the virtue of obedience
more embellished and bright.
That's why I ignore them.
So Louise says, "Afterward I looked at his most beautiful face and in my interior I felt
an indescribable contentment and turning to him I said, 'My most sweet love, if I take
so much delight in looking at you, what must it be for our Queen Mother?
When you enclosed yourself in her most pure womb, what contentment how many graces did
you not give to her?'
And he said, 'My daughter, the delights and the graces that I poured into her were so
great and so many that it's enough to tell you that what I am by nature, my mother became
by grace.'
Now the church has known that for all of its life, for all of its history, it's John
1927.
For so, since she had no sin in her, therefore my grace was able to lord freely within her.
The lord freely is to rule and to reign.
And therefore my grace was able to rule freely within her.
There is nothing of my being which I did not give to her.
That's the most incredible statement.
You see, there was literally no opposition in Blessed Mother's soul to the lord.
And so the lord gave himself fully to her, and so far as a creature could take that fullness.
At that instant, Louisa said, 'I seem to see our Blessed Mother as if she were another
God which you would have to put in inverted commas.'
Psalm 82 verse 5, 'I said you are God's, all of you sons of the most high.
God's there with the small G.
With this difference alone, that in God this is his own nature, while in Mary most holy
it is acquired by grace.'
Who can see how stupefied I was left, how my mind was lost in seeing a portent of grace
so prodigious?
So turning to him I said, 'My dear God, our mother had so much good because you let yourself
be seen intuitively.'
I would like to know, how do you show yourself to me?
Is it by abstractive or by intuitive sight?
It's a very, very important question.
And the answer is going to be very illuminative for us.
Who knows whether it is even abstractive at all?
And he said, 'I want to make you understand the difference that passes between one and
the other.
In the abstractive, the soul contemplates God, while in the intuitive she enters into him
and obtains graces.'
So one is, 'You're looking at God from the outside and the other one is you're entering
into him.'
Which one is better?
It's better to enter into him.
That is, she receives within her the participation in the divine being.
How many times have you not participated in my being?
That suffering which seems almost natural to you, that purity by which you reach the point
of feeling as if you don't even have a body, and many other things, have I not communicated
this to you when I have drawn you to myself intuitively?
What a marvelous, marvelous passage that is.
'Our Lord, it's so true,' Louisa said, 'and I, what thanks have I rendered you for this?
What has been my response to you?
I feel blushing at the mere thought of it, oh please forgive me, and let it be known in
heaven and on earth that I am an object of your infinite mercies.'
And that's what he's doing through these writings.
So September the 30th, 1899, this is a very important message about patience during temptation.
Jesus says, 'Earlier I spent more than one hour in hell, in passing I went about looking
at the image of baby Jesus and a thought like lightning said to the baby how ugly you are.'
I try not to pay attention to it, nor to become disturbed.
You see, Jesus doesn't want her to be disturbed about anything.
In order to avoid some game with the devil, yet in spite of this, that diabolical lightning
penetrated into my heart, and I felt that my poor heart was hate in Jesus, I, yes, I felt
I was in hell keeping company with the damned, I felt love changed into hate, oh God, what
pain being unable to love you.'
So Louisa said, 'Lord, it is true that I am not worthy to love you, but at least accept
this pain, that I would want to love you, but cannot.'
Now there is a very important prayer.
If you are unable to pray for whatever reason that you just admit to the Lord that you can't
do it, but that you would like to do it, and then ask your guardian angel to pray for you
and ask your patron saints and ask blessed mother, and you'll be fine.'
So after spending more than one hour in hell, Louisa said, 'It seemed I got out of it,
thank God.'
But who can say how afflicted and weakened my poor heart was left because of the war
fought between hate and love?
I felt such prostration of strength that it seemed to me I had no more life.
Then I was caught by my usual state, but all have worn out my heart and all my interior
powers which with unspeakable yearning desire to go in search of their highest and only
good, that's Song of Songs chapter 3 verses 1 to 4.
And when they find him, only then do they stop and enjoy him to their greatest contentment.
This time they did not even dare to move because she's exhausted.
They were so annihilated, confused and sunken their nothingness.
Now notice they sunk in their nothingness, I want you to keep noticing that all the time,
that they did not let themselves be heard, O God what a cruel blow my heart had to suffer.
In spite of all this, my always kind and loving Jesus came, and his consoling sight made me
forget immediately that I had been in hell so much so that I did not even ask Jesus
forgiveness.
The interior powers which are intellect, memory and will, humiliated and tired as they were
seemed to rest in him, that is Psalm 62, rest in God my soul.
Everything was silence, so that it's complete rest, that's what that silence is, that depth
of silence.
On both sides there was nothing but a few loving glances that wounded each other's heart.
After remaining in this profound silence for some time, Jesus said, my daughter, I'm hungry,
give me something.
And Louisa said I have nothing to give you.
But at that very instant I saw a loaf of bread and I gave it to him because he's in
and out of the body experience so things are not the same as on earth.
I gave it to him and he seemed to eat it with all pleasure.
Now in my interior I kept saying, it's been a few days since he told me something.
And Jesus answered my thought because in the spirit world you don't need to use words
in order to communicate, all the communication is done by intellect.
Jesus answered my thought, sometimes he said, the groom is pleased to deal with his bride
and to entrust his most intimate secrets to her.
At other times when he delights with great pleasure in resting as they contemplate each
other's beauty, now song of songs chapters four and chapter six is the bridegroom and
the bride contemplating each other with love.
So in this resting speaking impedes resting and the mere thinking of what one has to say
and a thought one has to deal with diverts one's attention from looking at the beauty
of the groom or of the bride.
However, this is needed.
In fact, after they have rested and understood each other's beauty more, they love each other
more and with greater strength, sorry, and with greater strength they enter the field
again to work to negotiate and to defend their interests.
Now for that first part I want to give you Sam 116 verse 7 and Matthew 1128 for the rest
come and rest in May.
And for entering the field to work in their interests I want to give you the song of songs
chapters 11 and 12.
So after the bride and the bridegroom enjoy each other's company then they go out into
the field of the world to look after souls.
So he said this is what I'm doing with you, aren't you happy?
Then Louisa said after this a thought flashed through my mind about the hour spent in hell.
And immediately I said Lord forgive me how many offences I've given to you.
And he said do not want to afflict or disturb yourself.
It is I who leads the soul deep into the abyss to then be able to lead her more quickly to
heaven.
In other words the way up is down.
The way to the heights of heaven is through the annihilation of our wills to go into our
nothingness and to have to experience temptation and struggle upon the earth.
Then he made me understand that that loaf of bread that I found was nothing but the patience
with which I had borne that hour of bloody battle.
Yeah that's a very important thing for us to realize that we don't like the struggle
and we think there's something wrong if we're struggling.
But the struggle is actually very important.
And the Lord is telling us that in that struggle if we're patient and if we just try to stay
doing the will of God and continuously giving ourselves to God and declaring before heaven
earth and hell that we do not want to sin we only want the will of God then we are producing
food or loaf of bread for Jesus.
Therefore patience, humiliation and offering God what one suffers in time of temptation
is nourishing bread that one gives our Lord which he accepts with great pleasure.
So that should put a different blossom on the times when we're actually struggling.
On October 1st 1899 Jesus speaks with bitterness about the abuses of the sacraments.
That's over a century ago.
This morning my beloved Jesus continued to make himself seen in silence but with the
most afflicted appearance he had a thick crown of thorns driven into his head.
I felt my interior powers silent that's the intellect, memory and will and I didn't dare
to say a single word.
But in seeing that he suffered very much in his head I stretched out my hands and very
carefully removed the crown of thorns.
But what a bitter spasm he suffered.
How his wounds opened more and the blood poured out in torrents.
In truth it was something that tortured the soul.
After I removed it I placed it on my head and Jesus himself helped.
So that it might penetrate inside because that's the problem the prick on the outside
is nothing.
It's when it penetrates the head.
However everything was silent on both parts.
So here you have the two of them completely at one in wanting to carry on this relationship.
But what was my surprise when after a little while I went about looking at him again and
I saw that with their offenses creatures were putting another crown on the head of Jesus.
What human perforty.
Now that's Jeremiah.
I think it's 17.
I can't remember the verse at this moment where Jeremiah says that the human heart is
perverse.
All incomparable patience of Jesus how great you are and Jesus kept silent and almost
did not look at them.
So as not to know who the offenders were.
Look at the charity and the kindness there.
Again Louisa said I removed the crown and as all my interior powers woke up with tender
compassion all my interior powers intellect memory and will woke up with tender compassion
I said to him my dear good my sweet life tell me a little bit.
Why do you no longer tell me anything you've never been used to hiding your secrets from
me.
Oh please let us speak together a little for in this way we will pour out a little bit
of sorrow and love that oppresses us.
So I want to give you Galatians 617 for Louisa sharing the crown of thorns with Jesus.
Jesus said my daughter you are the relief for my pains.
However know that I do not tell you anything because you always force me not to chastise
people.
She has to know why this silence happens and why he doesn't tell her anything.
You want to oppose justice and if I do not do what you want you remain disappointed and
I feel more pain in not keeping you content because he loves her.
Therefore in order to avoid displeasure on both parts I keep silent.
Now she should know at this stage that the silence is usually to do with chastisement.
Louisa said my good Jesus have you perhaps forgotten that you yourself suffer after you
have made use of your justice.
It is seeing you suffer in the creatures themselves because the divine will is present in every
person and in every thing.
The divine will is omnipresent.
So if creatures on earth suffer chastisement then the divine will in them also suffers.
It is seeing you suffer in the creatures themselves that makes me more than ever alert enforcing
you not to chastise the people.
And then seeing them themselves turning against you like many poisonous vipers such that they
would almost take your life if it was in their power because they see themselves under
your scourges.
So Louisa has a double problem here that many human beings will not turn to God under the
scourge.
They will turn to cursing him and rejecting him.
She said because they reject you because they see themselves under your scourges and they
irritate your justice even more, I don't have the heart to say "fiat volontas tua"
your will be done.
So in the next long section Jesus begins to tell her what the problem is and he tells
her the state of the church and it's not funny.
He said my justice can take no more.
I feel wounded by everyone, by priests, by devout people, we would say religious people
and laity who are committed to the Lord.
And by secular that means people outside the church, especially because of the abuse
of the sacraments.
Some do not care about them at all, adding despises, in other words they despise them.
Others who attend them turn them into a conversation for their own pleasure.
And others not satisfied in their whims because of this reach the point of offending me, oh
how tortured my heart is in seeing the sacraments reduced to painted pictures, in other words
no reality behind them.
Or like those statues of stone that seem to be alive and operating from afar, you mean
ventriloquists.
Something dead and a voice comes through it.
Oh dear, what's the condition of the priest if he's called a ventriloquist?
They're like those statues of stone that seem to be alive and operating from afar.
But as one draws nears them, one begins to discover the deceit.
For that I want to give you SAM 115.
The idols have eyes and they do not see, they have ears and they do not hear, they have
lips and they do not speak and so on and so on, they have hands and they do not work.
And yet what they, pagan priests of old learned was that if they could manage to get a voice
speaking through the idol that they could deceive the people into thinking that the
idol was real.
There's a story at the end of the book of Daniel exposing all of this deception.
Then when one goes touching these statues of stone, what does he find?
Paper, stone, wood, inanimate objects and here is how they are disillusioned completely.
This is how the sacraments have been reduced for the most part, there is nothing but mere
appearance.
That to me is very frightening, to Timothy 3.5, Matthew 15, 19 and 20.
What to say then about those who remain more filthy than clean?
In other words, they live immoral lives.
And then the spirit of financial interest that reigns among the religious, oh dear, Matthew
15, 8 to 9.
It's something to be wept over.
Now, Louisa lives in Italy and at this time, and it went on into the early part of the
20th century, families who owned lands or had big businesses would put a son into the
priesthood and when he was ordained, then they would put him in charge of running their
lands or running their businesses, which of course destroyed the man's vocation if he
had one in the beginning because he got involved in all kinds of worldly affairs.
That's what Jesus is saying, and then the spirit of financial interest that reigns among
the religious, now, some men in religious communities were also involved, it's something
to be wept over, he said.
Don't you think that they are all eyes when there's a most wretched penny, oh dear, Jesus
told us you cannot serve God and money, it's not actually possible.
And yet the terrible thing that Satan does with people consecrated to God is that he
tries to draw them into money and power, and of course, you don't get money and power
by themselves, money, sex and power is what you is used to bring down the human race and
the church has been attacked viciously in all three ways.
So Matthew 15 verses 13 and 14.
So they're all eyes when there's a most wretched penny to be got at the point of degrading
their dignity, but where there is no interest, that means you can't actually benefit, they
have no hands, no feet, not a tiny bit.
The spirit of interest fills their interior so much, we would say making money fills them
so much that it overflows outside to the point that the secular people, that means the people
outside the church feel the stench of it and are scandalized by it, and this causes them
to give no credence to their words.
Now the word secular seems to include the laity, because the laity are living in the
world and also the people in society who may not be in the church, okay?
And they're scandalized when they see the priests who are worldly and involved in business
and so on, and getting pulled down by these terrible temptations.
And therefore when the priest then goes to teach, nobody listens to them because they
know the priest is living.
Ah yes, no one spares me, he says.
There are some who offend me directly, and some who though they could prevent so much
evil don't even bother, that's one of the problems that we're still dealing with today
in the church, and that is, if the bishops and the cardinals don't actually deal with
the problems that have been presented to them, even our secular society today holds
them accountable.
So I do not know to whom to turn Jesus said, but I will chastise them in such a way as
to render them incapable and some I will destroy altogether, oh dear.
So that would be Revelation 11, 18, I will destroy the destroyers of the earth, okay?
They will reach such a point that churches will remain deserted, but no one to administer
the sacraments, now that has already happened in Russia in the first half of the 20th century,
and the churches didn't recover until the very end of the century.
So interrupting his message, all frightened, Louisa said, Lord, what are you saying?
If there are some who abuse the sacraments, there are also many good daughters who receive
them with due dispositions and who would suffer very much if they couldn't attend them.
He said, too scarce is their number.
You see, he's seeing the whole thing globally and she can see it only from her little point
of view.
And therefore, our vision is myopic because we don't see the full platform.
And he says their number is far too few and then their pain for not being able to receive
them will work as reparation for me.
And will also make them victims for those who abuse them.
Louisa said, who can say how tormented I was left with these words of blessed Jesus, but
I hope that he will placate himself in his infinite mercy.
So October the 3rd, 1899, Louisa deals with lady obedience again.
And then we have another message about priests.
This morning Jesus continued to make himself seen afflicted.
I didn't have the courage to say even one word to my most patient Jesus for fear that
he might resume his plaintive speech about the state of the religious.
In other words, she couldn't take anymore.
This because obedience wants me to write everything.
Now, the priest has gotten down to the fact that Louisa doesn't write everything she hears.
And so he's beginning to give her an obedience to write, but Jesus has also told her.
Now even though this is so, Louisa has such a repugnance to writing that she will still
be struggling with this in volume six and seven.
Obedience wants me to write everything.
And also that which regards charity towards one's neighbor.
That was the bit she was hoping obedience would forget.
And this is so painful for me that I had to fight by the force of my arms with lady
obedience.
More so since she changed her appearance into that of a most powerful warrior armed with
these weapons to give me death.
In truth, I found myself in such constraints that I myself do not know what to do.
To write about charity towards one's neighbor, according to the light that Jesus made me
see, seems impossible to me.
That's why the priest wants it so badly.
I felt my heart being wounded by a thousand prickings.
I felt my mouth being struck dumb and my courage failing me.
And I said to obedience, dear obedience, you know how much I love you and that for love
of you I would gladly give my life, but I see that I am not able to do this.
I can't do it.
You yourself can see the torture of my soul.
Here you need to remember that Louisa has no education, not even primary school education.
So she's being asked to write something of extremely high mystical theology for someone
who has no education.
So it is an extraordinary challenge for her.
"Oh please," she said, "do not make yourself an enemy.
Don't be so ruthless with me.
Be more indulgent with one who loves you so much, oh please, you yourself come to me and
let us discuss together what is the most appropriate thing for me to do," or to say.
So it seemed that she laid down her fury and she herself dictated what was most necessary.
In closing in a few words, the whole sense of the different things that regarded charity.
In other words, the priest gave her a couple of headings and that and said, "Look, why
can't you deal with it from this particular angle" and so on.
At times, however, obedience wanted me to be more detailed and I would say to her it's
enough that they understand the meaning with a little bit of reflection.
So Louisa thinks everybody else is contemplating at the depth that she is.
Isn't it better to enclose all the meaning in one word instead of many words, Louisa
said?
At times, obedience would surrender others I would and so it seems that we got along.
How much patience it takes with this blessed lady obedience, do you remember she has already
told us, I think it was in Volume 1, how much patience she had to have dealing with Jesus.
She doesn't yet realize that in dealing with Jesus, she's dealing with obedience and vice
versa.
How much patience it takes with this blessed lady obedience, truly a lady for it is not
to give her the right to Lord and that changing her appearance into the most meek lamb, she
herself makes the sacrifice of toiling and allows the soul to rest in her Lord, placing
herself around her with vigilant eye so that no one may dare to molest her and to interrupt
her sleep.
And while the soul sleeps, this is Sam 127, what does this noble lady do?
She drips sweat from her forehead, hastening the toil that belonged to the soul, something
that truly causes every human mind the most intelligent to be stupefied and shakes every
heart to love her.
So now while I'm saying this in my interior, I kept saying, but what is this obedience?
What is it made of?
What is the nourishment that sustains it?
And Jesus made his harmonious voice heard externally in my hearing.
He said, do you want to know what obedience is?
This is the quintessence of love, obedience is the finest, the purest, the most perfect
love, and it is extracted from the most painful sacrifice.
To destroy oneself in order to live again from God, out of God.
In most noble and divine, obedience tolerates nothing human in the soul and nothing which
does not belong to it.
So this is real obedience demands death to self.
Therefore, all its attention is on destroying within the soul everything which does not
belong to the divine nobility, that is, it must destroy the love of self.
This is why the obedience demanded of Louisa was total because total death to self was
required.
Unfortunately, today in the church and in society, obedience is not understood, it's
not appreciated, it's not loved, it's not carried out.
And once obedience has done this, that is, killed off love of self, it cares very little
about whether it alone struggles and toils on behalf of the soul while allowing the soul
to rest peacefully.
Finally, I myself am obedience, wow.
Louisa was up against Jesus all the time, absolutely demanding that she would be like
him in every possible way, every dot and every comma.
This will be quite a shock for her.
So now Jesus has told us since volume one, I am faith, I am hope, I am love, I am truth,
I am the life, I am obedience, watch this gathering momentum as we go along.
That's why in the divine will prayers we call him the all, he's everything.
Oh, who can say how amazed and ecstatic I remained on hearing these words of blessed
Jesus, oh holy obedience, how incomprehensible you are, I prostrate myself at your feet and
I adore you, Romans 9 11, and I pray you to be my guide, teacher and light along the
disastrous path of life, Deuteronomy 32 15.
So that guided, instructed and escorted by your most holy light with certainty, I may
take possession of the eternal harbor.
Now the problem is solved.
If Jesus himself is obedience, then it means that all she's got to do is throw herself
on him.
If he wants something, you can't do it, he can do it.
And that's why in the divine will you hear it being said all the time that Jesus says,
if you desire it, I'll do it.
We only have to throw ourselves upon him and throw our nothingness into his allness.
That's all.
So Louisa says, I stop here almost forcing myself to go out of this virtue of obedience,
otherwise I would never stop speaking.
So much is the light of this virtue that I see that I could endlessly continue writing
about it because she's writing about the Lord.
But other things call me and therefore I keep silent and I go back to where I left.
So I saw my sweet Jesus afflicted and remembering that obedience had told me to pray for a certain
person.
With all my heart I commended him to the Lord.
And Jesus told me, my daughter, may he make all his works shine with virtue alone.
She's praying for a priest to see.
And so all his works to shine with virtue alone.
But especially I recommend that he do not meddle in the things of family interest.
Oh, oh, if he has something material, let him give it away.
That's Luke chapter 6 and Luke chapter 12.
He does not want priests involved in secular stuff.
I don't want him to get involved with anything else.
God is jealous.
And if you give yourself to him, he wants the whole of you.
This priest should let things be done by those who are supposed to do them.
In other words, let the secular deal with the secular or as Jesus said to a young man
who wanted to be a disciple, he said, let the dead bury the dead.
Let the secular deal with the secular, you come into the kingdom of God.
So he does not want priests involved in either commerce or politics.
And while he should remain disentangled, free without getting muddy with earthly things,
otherwise he would encounter the misfortune of the others who, since they wanted to meddle
in some things in their family business from the beginning, all the way then fell upon
their shoulders.
And I, only because of my mercy, had to permit that they would not prosper, but rather become
poorer, so as to let them touch with their own hands how unseemly it is for a minister
of mine to solely himself with earthly things.
So Jesus said here that other priests who got involved, he had to step in and let them fail
so that the family would let them go and he would be able to be a priest.
On the other hand, this is a word that came from my mouth.
The ministers of my sanctuary, as long as they do not touch earthly things at all, would
never lack their daily bread.
That was the promise made to all priests in the Old Testament, Deuteronomy 18 2.
And the rule was that the church was to support the pastors.
The pastors were to feed the people spiritually and the people would support them in their
material needs.
That's the reason why we give donations on a Sunday.
Now with these ones, if I had allowed them only to prosper, the ones who get involved,
they said, they would have solid their hearts and they would have cared neither about God
nor about the things pertaining to their ministry.
And then, bothered and tired of their state, they would want to shake it off, but they
cannot because priesthood leaves a permanent mark.
And this is the penalty for what they shouldn't do.
But so many priests in our lifetime, thousands of them have walked away, and they've gone
away to other things.
But the mark of the priesthood will be there even on the day of judgment.
And then we'll see how sad it was for them.
Priesthood is a permanent state.
You cannot leave it.
Louisa says, "After this, I commended a sick person to Jesus, and he showed him his wounds,
which that sick person had given to him.
In other words, that there's justice in the sickness.
I tried to pray Jesus to placate him to repair him, and it seemed that those wounds would
heal.
And Jesus all kindness said to me, 'My daughter, today, you have performed for me the office
of a most skillful doctor, for you have tried not only to medicate and to bandage the wounds
that the sick person gave to me, in other words, healing involved reparation, but also
to heal them.
So I feel very much suited and placated."
Then Louisa said, "I understood that by praying for the sick one comes to perform the office
of doctor for our Lord, who suffers in these very images.
In other words, Jesus suffers in each one of us."
So the image is Genesis 1, 27, and Romans 8, 29.
So October 7, 1899.
Jesus is indignant with the people.
This morning, blessed Jesus was not coming, and I had to have very much patience in waiting
for him.
In my interior, I kept saying, "My dear Jesus, come, don't make me wait so much.
I haven't seen you since last night, and now it's getting late and you're still not coming."
She finds his absence completely intolerable.
See how much patience I've had in waiting for you.
Oh, please, do not let it be that I reach the point of losing patience because of your
long delay in coming, because then you would be the cause of it with your delays, therefore
come, for I can take no more.
And while I was saying this another nonsense, Jesus came, but to my highest sorrow, I saw
him almost indignant with the people.
Immediately, I said to him, "My good Jesus, I pray you to make peace with the world."
And he said, "Daughter, I can not.
I am like a king who wants to enter into a house, but that house is full of filthy things.
It's full of rot and of many other dirty things.
The king, as king, has the power to enter.
And there's no one who could prevent him from entering.
And he could even clean the house with his own hands, but he doesn't want to do it, because
it's not decent for his royal person to descend to such baseness.
And until that house is cleaned by someone else, in spite of the fact that he has the
power, the will, and the great desire to do it, to the point of suffering for it, he will
never dain to set foot in that place.
Hebrews 12, 14, "Nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God."
If you go to the book of Revelation as well, in chapters 21 and 22, where you get a description
of the New Jerusalem on the earth, you're told that everything unworthy is outside of
the city.
Jesus said, "That's what I'm like, I am a king who can and wants, but I want their will.
I want them to remove the rot of sins."
In other words, we have to repent.
And it's perfectly clear in the Gospels that Jesus was most kind to even public sinners
once they repented.
Nowadays, people think that God should agree with their sins and they think that's mercy.
I want them to remove the rot of their sins, so you need to read Isaiah chapter 40.
Before I enter and make peace with them, no, it's not decent for my royalty to enter and
make peace with them.
On the contrary, I will do nothing but send chastisements.
The fire of tribulation will inundate them everywhere to the point of knocking them down
so that they may remember that God actually exists.
Because that's the problem with many sinners today, that they have long since forgotten
that God exists.
And God is the only one who can help them and free them.
So Louisa, interrupting Jesus, said to him, "Lord, if you want to lay hand on chastisements,
I want to come.
I no longer want to be on the earth.
How will my heart be able to resist in seeing your creatures suffer?"
Now, what Louisa doesn't realize is that Jesus is speaking to her prophetically.
And I want to give you Amos 3, 7, that the Lord never does anything without telling the
prophets first.
And so some of the messages that Louisa was given happened in her own lifetime.
Some happened afterwards, and I think some still have to happen.
And Jesus assuming a kind appearance said to me, Louisa said, "If you come, where shall
I dwell upon the earth?"
Matthew 5, 8, "He can only dwell in the pure and heart."
For now let us think about being together down here that is on the earth, where we will
have plenty of time in heaven, we will have the whole of eternity.
And it's more important to work together down here.
Now, that's 2 Corinthians 5 verses 1 to 10.
You may want to go and be with God, but it's actually more important to stay on the earth.
And then you too have you forgotten your office of acting as my mother upon the earth.
She has forgotten it, you see.
So while I chastise the people, I will come and take refuge in you and dwell in you 1 Corinthians
3, 16.
Louisa said, "Ah, Lord, what is the purpose of my state of victim for so many years?
What good has come to the people while you said you wanted me as a victim soul to spare
the people?"
Now she just doesn't realize the platform on which the Lord is speaking.
She's looking at it in a way that's far too myopic and small.
And now you show how these chastisements, instead of happening many years ago, are happening
later.
You see, she's beginning to realize that some things are happening now, some things happened
later, nothing more and nothing less than this.
And he said, "My daughter, don't say that.
I have been forbearing for love of you, and the good that came from this has been that
while terrible chastisements were to rage for a long time, they will in fact be shorter."
So she's having a much greater effect than she knows.
Is this not a good?
That instead of being under the weight of chastisement for many years, one remains only
for a few, if you take the two world wars, 1914 to 1918, and the second world war, '39
to '45, instead of it going on and on and on, in the past we had a 37-year war.
Or 30 years, I think it was.
Moreover, during the course of these past years with wars and sudden deaths, they should
not have had the time to convert, but they did, and they were saved.
That is Ezekiel 18, verses 21 to 23 and 30 to 32.
God doesn't want the death of the sinner, he wants them to convert and live.
Is that not a great good, Jesus said?
My beloved, for now, it's necessary to make you understand the purpose of your state for
yourself, as well as for the peoples.
And I will show it to you when you come to heaven, and on the day of judgment, I will
show it to all nations, therefore do not speak like this anymore.
We've had enough of this, we're going to stop there right now.